most of the people waiting in line at
the bank already have five thousand and
one thousand rupee bills but they've
been invalid for two weeks patiently
almost a pathetically they tried to
exchange the money or get into their
bank account on Wednesday the All India
Trinamool Congress party let their
voices be heard their protest in India's
capital was directed towards the Indian
Prime Minister his decision was bad for
the little guy and actually missed its
target Modi had promised before
elections that he would get back to
black money but what happened ultimately
the common man is facing problems and we
can't get our own money is that the
black money many members of parliament
also protested on Wednesday they belong
to the opposition and were also shocked
at Moody's decision they want answers
200 MPs from the opposition are here and
200 MPs want the Prime Minister to speak
in the lower house and tell the country
why he took this decision according to
estimates the monetary reform has made
about eighty-five percent of the cash in
circulation worthless overnight and the
new notes won't be available until the
end of December it's caused the Indian
economy to screech to a halt food
markets are considering closing down
because their customers have no money
small and mid-sized companies have
stopped production because they can't
pay their invoices